I'm so excited for career day one I may  look good DK how many listen kid I'm a  cool boss we're not a traditional  workplace what skills do you have in an  efficient and make a soft office maybe  we'll be in touch maybe we won't it's  all a big secret be Sam  Josh ally the Cardinals the Raiders are  a great organization we're gonna burn it  to the ground man that's why a great bit  really working so just by looking at you  I think you're definitely Broncos  quarterback material sir that's a mom  still I like that it's tall every year  this hurts my feelings hello I'm Mel  Kiper and I have ranked the children  [Music]  never mess with the Mannings on career  day  [Music]  subscribe to this channel and rot your  brain with more episodes YouTube it's a  distraction coach Coach coach quit coach  coach hey wait coach coach goes